Mal kurz ist mein Name. Ich bin hier als ersten Tati und heute kümmere ich mich um Sie.
Ich stelle die Ordnung für Sie.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist ja das Sinn, dass Sie nach mir gucken und dass mich jemand hilft.
Ah, ja, sehr gerne. Ich bräuchte erst Ihren persönlichen Daten. Wie heißen Sie den?
Ich heiße Peter Kaiser.
Peter Kaiser.
Ja.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, K, A, I, S, E, R.
Ja, Herr Kaiser, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 72 Jahre alt.
72 Jahre alt und wie sind Sie? Wie schwer und wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 178 groß oder war ich zumindest mal, steht so im Ausweis.
Vielleicht bin ich inzwischen ein bisschen kleiner geworden, aber ich wiege so 80 kg ungefähr.
80 kg, vielen Dank. Was fühlt Sie heute zu uns, Herr Kaiser?
Ich habe euch einen heftigen Hut. Der Husten wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Der ist schon seit Wochen jetzt.
Ich war bei meinem Hausarzt und der hat mir ACC verschrieben.
Das habe ich auch eigentlich genommen, aber das hat ich überhaupt nicht.
Jetzt ist es so, dass ich schon ganz erschöpft bin von den vielen Husten.
Ich kann nachts ganz schlecht schlafen, weil der Husten quält mich wirklich.
Und jetzt habe ich die letzten Tage mit einem auch hohes Fieber bekommen.
Da habe ich gedacht, jetzt komme ich direkt zu Ihnen ins Krankenhaus.
Ja, Sie haben sehr gut gemacht, uns zu kommen.
Und Fieber haben Sie seit gestern, ja?
Ja, gestern habe ich das erste Mal gemessen, vielleicht ist das schon ein paar Tage.
Das ist jetzt schlimm.
Ja, aber das war über 39 gestern Abend.
Da bin ich doch ein bisschen erschrocken.
Soll ich Ihnen Wasser bringen?
Nein, nein, das geht schon so.
Husten, gibt es auch Auspulver?
Nein, das ist ganz komisch.
Das reizt immer nur und ist aber ganz trocken, da kommt gar nichts.
Reis-Husten, ja, trocken.
Haben Sie auch Atemnot?
Wenn so ein Husten-Attack so ganz schlimm ist, gerade Nacht,
da kann das Stommer passieren, dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich kriege keine Luft,
da muss ich das Fenster aufmachen, ja?
Aber nur beim Husten-Anfälle?
Ja, sonst habe ich keine Atemnot, nein.
Seit einer, woher husten Sie so stark?
Das ist schon länger, das ist schon fast drei Wochen.
Aber mit dem Fieber ist das jetzt erst gekommen.
Okay, seit drei Wochen husten Sie vermehrt, ja?
Ja, aber es wird immer schlimmer, ne?
Immer schlimmer geworden, im Laufe der Zeit.
Haben Sie laufende Nase oder verstoffte Nase?
Nein, das nicht.
Hast Schmerzen?
Höchstens so ein bisschen ein Kratter von der ewigen Husterei,
dass das so ein bisschen raub ist.
Aber nicht dieses typische Vorher, dass ich das Gefühl hatte,
ich habe schlimme Halsschmerzen.
Okay, und O-Rennschmerzen vielleicht?
Oder Kopfschmerzen ganz vorne?
Also, was ich gemerkt habe, als es mit dem Fieber losging,
dass ich so allgemein so mich schlecht gefühlt habe,
dass ich so ein bisschen Gliederschmerzen und Kopfschmerzen hatte.
Aber das ist erst jetzt, seit es mit dem Fieber losgegangen ist.
Okay, wenn der Fieber kommt, haben Sie auch Glieder und Kopfschmerzen.
Aber ansonsten, Husten ist im Vordergrund.
Ja, ja.
Haben Sie Schluckprobleme beim Schlucken?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Knoten am Halsbereich bemerkt,
vergrößerte Knoten?
Hab ich nicht überprüft.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, wo ich da tasten sollte.
Also, das weiß ich nicht.
Okay, ja.
Und, ist diese Husten,
hat diese Husten plötzlich angefangen oder langedan?
Ich würde sagen, der hat ziemlich plötzlich angefangen.
Ja.
Plötzlich gibt es ein bestimmter Grund, zum Beispiel könnte es sein,
dass sie etwas inhaliert haben.
Sie meinen, dass ich mich bei irgendwas verschluckt habe?
Genau.
Nee, nee, sowas ganz bestimmt nicht.
Okay, ja, das ist gut.
Okay, Sie haben schon Fieber, ist Ihnen übert?
Ja, schlecht ist mir aber auch erst jetzt seit ein paar Tagen,
wobei auch manchmal, wenn diese Hustenattacken so ganz schlimm sind,
dann hat man das Gefühl, dass man so, dass es so wirkt,
dass man sich fast übergeben muss, ja.
Mhm, aber ich muss mich noch nicht übergeben.
Aber ich fühle mich jetzt wirklich, also mir ist schlecht
und ich fühle mich schlapp und fieber ich eben, ne?
Mhm.
Fieber auch, ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Herzstrasen?
Nein.
Ja, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich meine, also ich wieg mich jetzt nicht jeden Tag,
aber ich meine, ich wieg immer so um die 80 Kilo rum.
Okay, aber Ihr Appetit ist gut, ne, mich mal, oder nicht?
Also zurzeit eher nicht, aber sonst normalerweise schon.
Mhm, schlafen Sie gut?
Oder, also Sie will gern Husten gar nicht?
Husten kann ich jetzt überhaupt nicht gut schlafen, ja.
Also da hab ich das Gefühl, ich sitze die halbe Nacht
auf der Bettkante, ja.
Mhm, ich verstehe.
Und möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, Herr Kaiser?
Nein, das ist ja die Haupt-
Also dieser starke Husten und diese Fiebergeschichte,
das ist das, was mich am meisten Sorgen macht, ja.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Muss ich auch dazu sagen, wissen Sie, mein Bruder,
der hatte Lungenkrebs und ist da dran gestorben.
Und natürlich macht man sich Gedanken,
wenn man so lange so schreckliche Husten hat, ja.
Ja, wann ist er gestorben?
Ach, das schlägt schon ein paar Jahre zurück,
er ist auch älter als ich gewesen.
Er ist 77 geworden.
Mit 67 Jahren?
77.
77 Jahre?
Hat er, ist er gestorben?
Ja, ist er verstorben, ja.
Das tut mir sehr leid.
Das ist, das ist wahrscheinlich sehr schwierig für Sie.
Aber Krebs ist nicht ganz erdlich,
nicht 100% erdlich.
Ihre Beschwerden können auch andere Ursachen haben.
Natürlich werden wir aber alles untersuchen.
Jetzt möchte ich zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte übergehen,
wenn Sie noch nichts hinzugehen zu haben.
Hinzu zu finden haben.
Ja, okay.
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich Ihnen sonst noch erzählen soll.
Okay, gibt es chronische Erklankungen bei Ihnen,
zum Beispiel Blutdruck, Zuckerkranchen?
Ja, natürlich.
Mit meinem Alter wissen Sie doch, da hat man immer etwas, ja.
Blutdruck habe ich auch schon lange, schon seit 25 Jahren.
Und vor 15 Jahren hat man dann festgestellt,
dass ich diesen Alterszucker habe, ja.
Und ja, die Prostata macht mir auch ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten.
Das ist aber alles gutartig, hat man mir gesagt.
Aber die ist eben ja angeschwollen.
Und ab und zu habe ich da Probleme,
dass ich eben häufig auf die Toilette muss.
Oder auch, dass ich mal Schwierigkeiten habe, ja.
Entschuldigung, Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich habe nicht ganz gut verstanden.
Sie gehen häufig auf die Toilette.
Ja, ich muss, also ins besondere Nacht stehe ich allein schon,
also auch ohne Husten stehe ich wegen der Blase auf
und muss dann also ein, zwei Mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Okay, gut, dabei Ihnen eine Verlösung der Vorstehendrüse festgestellt?
Ja, ja, das hat man festgestellt.
Das ist bekannt.
Aber das ist in der Kontrolle, das ist bisher also alles nicht bösartig.
Wann wurde das festgestellt?
Das ist so fünf Jahre her und seitdem gehe ich regelmäßig zur Beruhelung zur Kontrolle.
Und Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit und vorstelle die Musik die größeren haben,
sie als Vorerkrankungen.
Das langt ja völlig hin, aber das ist halt, in meinem Alter hat ja jeder.
Ja, jeder hat in ihrem Alter, das ist in Ordnung.
Aber Blutzucker und Blutdruck ist gut eingestellt.
Ich habe hier Tabletten, also ich kriege Tabletten hier mit Formin,
nämlich für den Zucker, also dann nehme ich nur morgens eine Tablette
und dann habe ich die Tablette, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die heißt,
das ist ein Betablocker, da nehme ich auch morgens eine.
Bitte Blokka, der Name erinnern Sie sich nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht, ich kann nicht mischen, wenn mein Hausarzt fragen.
Okay, bei wem befinden Sie sich in Haus erst nicht bei Handlung?
Ja, bei Dr. Becker.
Ah, den Kollegen kenne ich schon, das ist gut.
Das ist gut, ja, dann können Sie ja anrufen.
Ja, werde ich mit ihm Kontakt abnehmen.
Und mit Formin, mit 4mg erinnern Sie sich daran.
Ja, ich weiß, kann das sein, das ist 850, ich glaube,
das sind 850 oder 800 oder ich weiß gar nicht,
das ist vertraubt.
Ja, 850, Sie haben das nicht gesagt.
Ja, wie nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe da noch etwas für die Prosta da,
habe ich auch noch eine Medikamente, ja.
Wie heißt das?
Das heißt Prosta-Gut.
Prosta-Gut.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht.
Da nehme ich immer mittags eine Tablette.
Mittags, genau.
Gut, wo werden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Kaiser?
Ja, auch, das ist schon ewig lange her.
Da hat man bei mir die geilen Blase rausgemacht, ja.
Mhm.
Hatten Sie Geiliglöschsteine?
Ja, ich glaube wohl, ja.
Ich hatte jedenfalls stark Geschmerzen
und bin dann in die Klinik gekommen
und dann hat man das eben operiert.
Als Kind habe ich natürlich mal eine Blindarm-Operation gehabt, ja.
Okay.
Geiliglöschsteine, wann wurde das entfernt?
Oder war ich so etwas über 50, also so 25 Jahre her?
Mhm, vor 25 Jahren.
Mhm.
Okay, waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein, im Ausland war ich nicht.
Okay, oder vielleicht hatten Sie einen Hotelausaufenthalt
in der letzten Zeit im Hotel, haben Sie übernachtet?
Nein, ich war immer zu Hause.
Okay.
Und sind Sie gegen alle impflichtige Krankheiten
so wie gegen Covid-19 vollständig geimpft?
Gegen Covid bin ich nicht, ich bin nicht impft.
Ja, ich habe ja auch mal ein Test gemacht zwischendurch.
Ja, gegen Covid bin ich impft, in meinem Alter muss man das ja machen.
Ja, das ist schon wichtig.
Gegen Grippe bin ich sogar auch geimpft.
Gegen Grippe auch gut, sehr gut.
Und gegen Lungeninstundung?
In jedem Alter, das ist auch empfohlen?
Ja, ich glaube, ich meine, das hat mein Hausarzt mir auch schon mal gesagt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das gemacht haben,
müsste ich tatsächlich nachgucken in meinem Impfpass.
Aber ich meine, wir haben das gemacht.
Haben Sie sich etwas kumpfwillig dabei?
Da muss ich mal gucken, oh, ich glaube, der liegt zu Hause auf dem Schreibtisch.
Das machen wir.
Das muss meine Frau den Nacht bringen, ja.
Ja, es ist jetzt nicht so wichtig.
Okay, Sie sind zu Hause ein Covid-Test, Schnelltest gemacht, ja?
Ich habe einen gemacht und in der Arztpraxis,
als ich damals gekommen habe, haben die auch mal einen gemacht, ja.
Das war negativ.
Ja, ja, ja, klar.
Ich verstehe.
So, gut.
Und reagieren Sie allergisch auf Medikamente
oder haben Sie eine Unverzweglichkeit gegenüber Lebensmitteln?
Ja, also alle gibt es Einzige,
wo ich ein bisschen allergisch reagiere bei Hausstaubmilben.
Da muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Da kriege ich vielleicht dann so Hustenattacken.
Aber da haben wir uns natürlich auch total drauf eingestellt.
Unsere ganzen Matratzen sind mit so einer Schutzfolie.
Ja.
Wir saugen ganz viel Staub
und haben eine ganz staubarme Umgebung.
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie Teppiche zu Hause?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Nein, glatte Böden, ne?
Ja, das ist gut.
Sonst nichts, ja?
Nein, sonst Medikamente, das ist nicht, dass ich da irgendwas habe.
Alles gut.
Jetzt möchte ich ein bisschen über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten erfahren.
Genau, Herr Kaiser.
Ja, das muss ich natürlich zugeben.
Zur Zeit habe ich das zwar jetzt wirklich eingelassen.
Mit dem Husten schmeckt wirklich keine Zigarette.
Aber ich habe schon praktisch mein ganzes Leben lang geraucht.
Ganzes Leben lang geraucht?
Ja, seit 50 Jahren kann man sagen.
Seit 50 Jahren, wie viele Zigaretten täglich haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, so ein Päckchen geht ja schon jeden Tag drauf, ja.
Ein Päckchen.
Ich würde Ihnen empfehlen,
Rauchen reduzieren.
Jetzt mache ich das schon automatisch.
Ja, mal gucken, vielleicht habe ich das ja im Rahmen dieser Geschichte.
Ja, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also Alkohol, ne.
Ein, zwei Flaschen Bier am Tag, ja.
Ein, zwei Flaschen Bier, jeden Tag.
Ja, so.
Eine zum Abendbrot oder eine noch zum Feierabend und dann Bier ausgetragen.
Aber ich trink nie Schnaps oder sowas.
Okay.
Haben Sie Erfahrung oder hatten Sie Erfahrung mit den Drogen?
Oh nein, nee, nee.
Also ich war als Erzieher tätig.
Und da sah man selber keine Drogenerfahrung.
Ja, nur eine Routine mit sich gefragt.
Nehmen Sie mich denn nicht, peinste nicht.
Gibt es chronische Erklankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihr Bruder an Nungenkrebs gestorben haben.
Nein.
Wie geht es denn mit Ihrem Mutter und Ihrem Vater aus?
Also meine Eltern sind natürlich längst tot, ne.
Ich bin ja schon ziemlich alt.
Mein Vater hatte eine Herzinfarkt, das weiß ich.
Aber der war ja auch schon über 80.
Und meine Mutter ist also weit auch über 80 geworden.
Also, die hatte glaube ich keinen chronischen Erkrankungsumst.
Woran ist sie gestorben?
Ich weiß nicht, Altersschwäche, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwann ist das Leben halt zu Ende.
Die Userheit ist unbekannt.
Du wüsst ich jetzt nicht, ja.
Ich verstehe.
Wo machen Sie beruflich, Herr Kaiser?
Ich bin jetzt natürlich Rentner.
Natürlich.
Was haben Sie beruflich gemacht?
Ich habe als Erzieher gearbeitet.
Erzieherin.
Ich bin da in Maden.
Sehr schön.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Wollen Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Ja, mit meiner Frau.
Die Kinder sind natürlich aus dem Haus.
Sie sind ja schon längst abends.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Wir hatten zwei Kinder.
Sie sind beide fit, ja.
Sie sind sogar schon Großvater.
Wie schön.
Herr Kaiser, jetzt sind wir am Ende unseres Geschüb-Pres angekommen.
Überlegen Sie mal.
Möchten Sie mir noch etwas sagen?
Sie haben ja jetzt viel gefragt.
Ich habe Ihnen auch viel erzählt.
Ich will jetzt natürlich nur wissen,
dass wir gegen diesen Husten tun können.
Ich bin langsam wirklich so erschöpft,
dass ich das nicht mehr lange durchgehe.
Das kann ich vorstellen, besonders in der Nacht.
Sehr unangenehm.
Sie können gar nicht schlafen.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann brauchen wir eine Röntgenaufnahme
und gegebenenfalls werden wir Blut abnehmen bei Ihnen.
Wenn alle befunden vorliegen,
werden wir sprechen, wie es weitergeht.
Das klingt doch gut.
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz im Wartezimmer.
Wir sehen uns in wenigen Minuten wieder.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn das keine exakte Zeit eine Planung ist.
Das ist neu, dass unsere Uhr immer mitläuft.
Sie haben sehr gut gehusst.
Ich habe es auch noch ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Wie kann ich helfen?
Ich wusste nicht.
Ich möchte jemand noch etwas fragen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben gestern Fieber, wo Sie gemessen haben?
Das ist unter der Achsel.
Sie haben eine bestimmte Zeitraum oder
granztage, wo Sie sind?
Ich wusste den ganzen Tag, aber nachts ist es unangenehm.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Hat jemand in Ihrer Umgebung
Hat jemand in ihrer Ungewung der ernehmliche Beschwerden hat oder hatten sie einen Kontakt mit jemandem, der hustet?
Gut, Husten tut immer irgendwo jemand. Wenn man einkaufen geht oder einen Bus fährt, da wird man schon mal angerustet.
Aber bei uns in der Familie, meine Frau hat nichts und sonst ist da ja keiner.
Okay, die andere Frage ist, haben Sie die Aufwischungsempfunden besonders gegen den Keuchusten machen lassen?
Da müsste ich mal ein Hausarzt fragen, das weiß ich nicht, das habe ich gar nicht so in Erinnerung.
Normalerweise in alle zehn Jahren müssen Sie diese Aufwischungsempfunden machen lassen.
Nach zehn Jahren, muss ich tatsächlich mal gucken, ob das gemacht worden ist, das kann ich nicht sicher sagen.
Haben Sie Ausruf? Nein, der Husten ist trocken.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie Brustschmerzen beim Ein- und Ausatmen?
Beim Ein- und Aus- und Minimal-E-Mehr beim Husten.
Nachtschweise habe ich vergessen, haben Sie Nachtschweise?
Nachtschweise, nö, habe ich nicht. Also, heute Nacht habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen geschwitzt, als ich so gefiebert habe, aber normalerweise habe ich keine Nachtschweise.
Wegen zu bei Klose habe ich gegessen.
Legen Sie flach oder können Sie?
Mit zwei Kissen.
Also jetzt zurzeit sitze ich fast im Bett, weil ich sonst gar nicht schlafen kann.
Aber normalerweise schlafe ich normal mit einem Kissen, aber wie gesagt, jetzt kann ich sowieso schlecht schlafen und dann habe ich aber auch das Bett sehr hochgestellt.
Haben Sie beim Geschwörung?
Eine Stellung meiner Beine, ob ich die bemerkt habe. Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Wenn Sie Ihr Berufszeichen verloten, beispielsweise?
Nein, nein, ich wusste nur.
Würden Sie starten mit Arzt-Arztgespräch oder waren Sie noch eine Minute zu haben?
Okay, für mich ist das.
Ja, wir können, von mir aus können wir los, wenn sonst niemand mehr Fragen hat.
Da kommt noch etwas.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit auswandt?
Hat sie gefragt, war ich nicht, nein.
Hat sie auch gefragt, ich habe nicht angewichterloren.
Zumindest ist es mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Atomprobleme?
Atomprobleme nicht im eigentlichen Sinne, nur beim akuten Husten-Anfall trinke ich natürlich keine Luft, ist ja klar.
Starten wir?
Ja.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, namens Peter Kaiser.
Er ist 72 Jahre alt, 1,78 m groß, wiege zur Zeit 80 kg.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seit ungefähr 4 Wochen bestehender, zunehmender Reispusten,
sowie wegen seit vorgestern bestehender Fieber.
Von einem Fieber von 39 Grad Celsius.
Begleitende bestehen Fatigue, Gliederschmerzen und gelegentliche Kopfschmerzen.
Er erzählte, dass er beim Hustenattacken, bei den Hustenattacken auch an Nausea und Dyspnoeleide.
Er könne in der Nacht wegen Husten nicht schlafen, einschlafen und nicht durchschlafen.
Er habe zu Hause, sowohl zu Hause als auch beim Hausarzt, ein Covid-Schnalltest durchgeführt.
Das wurde negativ erfolgt.
Das war negativ.
Das Ergebnis war negativ.
Vegetative Anamnese ergab, Husten bedickte Inappetenz, Insomnie und Nictury.
Bei den Vorerkrankungen gehören arterielle Hypertonie seit 25 Jahren, Diabetes meelitus typsiweid, seit 15 Jahren
und eine benigene Prostatehypertlase seit fünf Jahren.
Er wurde zweimal operiert wegen einer Polycystiktomie vor 25 Jahren und wegen einer Appendektomie in der Kindheit.
Laut Angaben des Patienten ist er vollständig geimpft und die Frage nach Hotelaufenthalts wurde verneint.
Aufgrund der bereits genannten Vorerkrankungen nehme Herr Kaiser regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Diese sind mitformen 850 mg morgens.
Das ist eine Hypertensierung in der Gruppe von BetaBlocker.
Der Name ist nicht erinnerlich.
Weswegen werde ich mich mit dem Hausarzt Dr. Becker in Verbindung setzen.
Noch ein Medikament gegen bedingende Prostatehypertlase, namens Prosta Gut, in unbekanter Dosierung mittags, nehme er ein.
Herr Kaiser reagiert allergisch auf Schausstadtminben, deren Folge Kusten sei.
Herr Kaiser braucht seit 15 Jahren eine Packung täglich.
Er trinkt ein, zwei Flöschen Bier täglich, droge in Konsum wurde verneint.
Familienanomnistisch erzählte Herr Kaiser, dass er Vater in einem Alter von über 80 an Myokardinfarkt gestorben ist.
Die Mutter ist auch über 80 Jahren gestorben, die Ursache sei unbekannt.
Sein Bruder ist 77 Jahre an Beugenkürz gestorben.
Herr Kaiser ist ehemaliger Erzieher, der ist verheiratet, wohne mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er habe zwei gesunde Kinder.
Angesichts der anomnistischen Angaben vermute ich in diesem Fall eine Pneumonie.
Gesellschaft kommt nicht auf die Pneumonie.
Nicht nasochomial, sondern gesellschaft, wie kann man sagen?
Ich kenne die Begriffe nicht, vielleicht kann da gleich jemand aushelfen.
Was ist die Differenzialdiagnose zur Pneumonie?
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen COPD oder Asthma, von hier mit einer Superinfektion mit einer Bakterie- oder Viralleräge.
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde die Lunge abhören, abtasten, inspirieren.
Die Lunge können Sie nicht sehen.
Die Brustkorb.
Vielleicht gibt es eine torakale Einziehung.
Bei der Palpation überprüfe ich, ob es Stimmpfremdus gibt.
Bei der Ausgultation überprüfe ich, ob es Rastelgeräusche oder Giemen, Brummen vorhanden ist.
Ausstatt der Blut- und Labountersuchung würde ich veranlassen, um eine mögliche Linkverschiebung, Leukosytos zu veranlisten.
Ich würde auch eine Entzündungsparameter wie CRP, BCG, Prochal-Sytonin analysieren lassen.
Elektrolyte und Leber und Nierenwerte können auch analysiert werden.
Ich würde eine Blutgas-Anelyse veranlassen.
Erst werde ich mit Fallparameter kontrollieren, damit meinte ich Blutzdruck, Sauerstoff-Setigung, Fieber-Messung und Alte-Mund-Herzfrequenz.
Was machen Sie im Labor außer der Blutuntersuchung?
Ein Rachen, nein. Ein Suppurtungkultur würde ich ins Labor schicken.
Sehr gut.
Und gegebenenfalls auf ein Blutkultur, falls ich ein Verdach auf Pneumonie oder Sepsis habe.
Und Röschgen-Porrax natürlich.
Ja, klar.
Gut, ja.
Wenn sich das bestätigt, was würden Sie mit dem Patienten machen, wenn er eine Pneumonie hat?
Falls es eine Pneumonie ist, also ich würde gerne auch eine empirische Antibiotika einleiten.
Was für eine Antibiotika haben Sie?
Im Brot-Spektrum.
Also breit-Spektrum?
Also praktisch noch ohne Definition des Keims.
Genau.
Dass man dann mit einem Antibiotikum schon mal drauf geht.
Aber ich vermute in diesem Fall auch eine atypische Pneumonie.
Es kann auch zum Beispiel Mikroplasma-Pneumonie sein.
Deswegen sollte die Antibiotiktherapie auch atypische Erreger umfassen.
Wie zum Beispiel Levofloxacin kann ein Optionen.
Ja.
Und Makrolitantibiotika, wie Kleintromissin, kann man auch einleiten.
Genau.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ja, natürlich werde ich, also wäret tagsüber kann man,
kann man Mikrolytykum und in der Nacht kann man Antitutivum beordnen.
Wie zum Beispiel Codein ist ein Wahl-
Unterärztlicher Kontrolle kann man das ja machen.
Würden Sie den Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Ja, also der Patient hat einen hohen Alltag.
Es gibt bestimmte Kriterien um den Patienten stationär aufnehmen
oder nicht.
Das ist Kurp C-U-R-B Stich 65.
Kurp 65.
Da steht Bluturea zum Beispiel, Arnsäuren.
Und ja, das ist Blutdruck ist auch wichtig.
Alltag ist wichtig.
Ja, in diesem Fall würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ja, das klingt doch gut.
Dann würde ich sagen, machen Sie jetzt Ihre Untersuchung
und wenn Sie Ihre Ergebnisse beieinander haben,
sprechen wir noch mal über den Patienten.
Und dann können wir Ihnen ja auch noch mal zusammen besuchen.
Ja.
Alles gut, wunderbar.
Gut, schön, danke.
Ja, ich danke Ihnen.
So, das war schön.
Haben Sie gut gemacht?
Sie haben eine schöne Ars-Berecht gemacht.
Ich würde sagen, das ist Nazokomialpinoemony
und Gesellschaft Erworbene Pinoemony.
Kann man sagen?
Dieses Gesellschaft Erworbene, das kann ich nicht.
Das kann ich nicht ambulant Erworbene hat.
Ambulant Erworbene, ja, richtig.
Ja, ja.
Also, Fakt ist, ein Kollege hat vorhin ganz ziemlich gezielt
nachgefragt nach der Pertussis-Impfung
und nach dem, und ob jemand anderes Kontakt
in der Familie auch hustet.
Und tatsächlich hat dieser Patient Koich husten.
Genau.
Ja, das ist für mich eigentlich auch überraschend.
Und ich erzähle Ihnen auch, warum ich diesen Fall heute ausgewählt habe,
weil ein alter Bekannte, da habe ich heute telefoniert mit der Frau
und die sagt, der Hausarzt vermutet, er hat Koich husten.
Und da habe ich gesagt, Mensch, ich habe doch einen Koich husten fallen,
den suche ich heute mal gleich raus.
Ja, deswegen sind Sie also heute an die Pertussis gekommen.
Ja.
Und Sie haben natürlich sehr schön auch die Differenz der Diagnosen
rausgearbeitet. Die Klavierie ist bei dem Alter natürlich
auch ebenso wahrscheinlich. Ja, klar.
Und was Sie selber ja schon gefragt haben,
fand ich auch spannend, dass Sie da zum ganz frühen Zeitpunkt
gefragt haben, ob es sein könnte,
dass deren Fremdkörper aspiriert hat.
Ja.
Und letztendlich auch Asthma und OCOPD kommen natürlich
in Frage, wenn es schon gibt, dass es eine Hausstaubmüllung
aller Diat. Sie waren also auf einer sehr, sehr guten Pferde.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, eigentlich sind nur zwei Winzigkeiten.
Das eine, Sie haben im Anamnesebereich auch wieder ziemlich
häufig gefragt, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie.
Haben Sie Schmerzen, haben Sie,
das, was ich, haben Sie nachts schweißt, haben Sie, also,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen. Das, ich möchte noch fragen, ob Sie,
ja, man kann das mit indirekten Fragen ein bisschen
eleganter und abwechslungsreicher machen, damit es nicht so
eine, so eine Liste ist, ne? So, das ist das eine.
Dann, Sie haben sich eigentlich ganz gut geschlagen
mit dem Anfangssatz, stellte sich heute Morgen Wegen.
Ja.
Wegen steht eigentlich mit dem Genitiv. Also müsste man dann sagen,
Wegen.
Einig Hustens.
Ja, Wegen langfristig bestehen, denn Hustens und Schivers.
Ja, aber das machen natürlich die Allerwenigsten heute.
Aber nicht Wegen bestehen der Fieber.
Nee, das geht nicht. Also wenn schon dann den Dativ nehmen,
wenn das mit dem Genitiv nicht klappt, aber dann richtig, also
Wegen bestehen den Fieber. Und Sie haben ein bisschen geschummelt.
Sie haben gesagt, er hat seit vier Wochen Husten,
aber er hat gesagt, er hat nur seit drei Wochen Husten.
Ja, Sie haben also eine Woche draufgepackt.
Ja.
Und genau, eine sprachliche Klippe ist mir noch aufgefallen.
Der Bruder hatte Bronchalkarzinom und er ist daran gestorben.
Nicht er habe daran gestorben.
Ja, also er sei daran gestorben, aber, ne?
Also Sterben ist eines der wenigen Sterben und Einschlafen,
glaube ich. Das sind die einzigen Verben, wo eigentlich keine Bewegung ist.
Ja.
Aber wo wir das perfekt bilden mit Seinen.
Ja, also das sind so sprachliche Spitzwendigkeiten.
Aber ansonsten haben sie sich sprachlich wirklich sehr,
sehr gut geschlagen.
Und Sie haben eigentlich auch gut reagiert.
Er hat ja zwischendurch auch viel geredet.
Ja, und ihnen Zusatzinformationen gegeben.
Die haben sie aber eigentlich auch schon gut eingebaut.
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, Sie haben,
haben Sie gut aufgepasst und haben das ja schön gelöst.
Also ich meine, Sie können sehr entspannt Ihre Prüfung entgegennehmen.
Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank für die Kommentare.
Das sind sehr wichtig für mich, meine Fehler zu korrigieren.
Und kann man sagen, er kann heute zu uns mit seit drei Wochen bestehenden posten.
Bestehendem, mit wem?
Bestehendem.
Mit dem Dativ.
Das ist gemalt.
Aber ich finde auch mit ist ein bisschen einfacher.
Ja, und Sie haben das aber eigentlich auch gut gemacht.
Sie haben nicht versucht, alle Informationen in diesen Einsatz rein zu packen.
Da liegt mir immer viel daran, dass man nicht so ein endloses Satz produziert,
bei dem man am Ende nicht mehr weiß, wie man angefangen hat.
Er stellt es sich bei uns vor mit und das vor kommt zwar eigentlich ans Ende,
aber bevor ich das dann da vergesse, dann mache ich es lieber so.
Also ich hoffe, dass die Münchner Prüfer entsprechend das auch so sehen wie ich.
Okay, die Hotel-Prage, die Legionär-Pinodigie.
Ich habe mich schon gewundert.
Ich habe überlegt, worauf Sie raus wollen.
Und auf die legionären Idee bin ich nicht gekommen.
Ich dachte, Hausstaub und Bettstaub oder so.
Aber wahrscheinlich sind irgendwo die Betten so gut gesaugt wie im Hotel.
Für mich war es gut.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Kollegen sagen.
Dr. Pupel ist unser Host.
Der muss mal etwas dazu sagen.
Vielen Dank.
Das war ausführlich eine Musikgespräch.
Und die Vorstellung war sehr gut.
Ich glaube, Frau Gülsach, Sie können vermeiden extra oder übermäßige Informationen für die Vorstellung.
Was meinen Sie mit übermäßiger Information?
Ich finde, ein bisschen länger Satz.
Vielleicht könnte gefährlich in der Püfung extra Informationen auslöschen.
Für extra Fragen auslösen.
Ich weiß, was Sie meinen.
Dass die Prüfer, wenn sie kurze Sätze machen und Informationen geben,
dass sie dann nochmal nachfahren zu einem Thema.
Damit müssen Sie natürlich rechnen.
Ich mache hier keine scharfe Fachprüfung.
Wir simulieren nur die Anamese und das Arztgespräch.
Der dritte Abstand, wo die bohrenden Fragen kommen, das steht mir nicht zu.
Da bin ich viel zu wenig Fachmann dafür.
Aber ich denke schon, dass Sie sehr entspannt reingehen können.
Alles klar.
Ich bin jetzt für heute einen schönen Abend.